(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] Santander,
Colombia, rich with wildlife
such as the majestic and
delicious big-ass ant.
(tape screeches)
I am so sorry for that
terrible impression.
Let's go and eat some ants.
Roll the title.
These are hormigas culonas
otherwise known as big-ass ants.
No, really that's the name.
Here in San Gil, people love to snack
on the little critters,
but to get them fresh
they have to move quick,
as they're only above
ground for one day a year.
Yes, that's 24 hours only
to get your ants fresh.
This is Adrian.
He's an expert when it
come to hunting them.
- [Narrator] Yeah, I'm like that
with the Flamin' Hot Cheetos.
Anyway, what if you're
looking for something
a little more restaurant-friendly?
What would you suggest, Elsa?
- [Narrator] And now the most
important part, the taste.
(moaning appreciatively) Pretty good.
Tastes like chicken.